[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing the
duration that witches and wizards live
haven't you ever wondered how old your
favorite characters are and how near
they actually are to kicking the bucket
the mortality seems to be heavily
touched on subject in Harry Potter
particularly because Voldemort was
intent on achieving it through the use
of Horcruxes but sometimes I wonder why
he was so compelled to achieve it
the truth is that on a physiological
level wizard kind isn't so different
from human kind besides the fact that
witches and wizards can perform well
magic the main difference is that
witches and wizards are less afflicted
by mundane illnesses injuries and
sicknesses were a bad cold could be bad
news for a very old amount of human it
may not be an issue for a witch or
wizard it's always implied throughout
the books and films that witches and
wizards live considerably longer than
their muggle counterparts but how much
longer why in an interview JK Rowling
was asked how old is old in the
Wizarding World and how old a
professor's Dumbledore and McGonagall to
which she responded Dumbledore is 115
and Professor McGonagall is a sprightly
17 witches have a much longer life
expectancy than muggles this made me
wonder if Dumbledore was a whopping 115
when he died with seemingly a lot of
natural life force what is the upper
limit of how long a wizard can expect to
live I think really besides a subtle
physiological differences some of the
main reasons for them living longer are
as follows number one witches and
wizards have access to better medicines
and medical remedies this means that
they're more effectively able to treat a
wide variety of illnesses and conditions
Wizarding medicine is particularly
advanced and where a human may suffer
from something like a potentially fatal
bone break their wizard counterpart
would be able to take advantage of a
potion like Skellig ro which either
mends broken bones or regrows them
entirely a broken bone can be fixed in
one night where a human may require cast
along with physical therapy for months
this is just a prime example of how much
more advanced Pacific medicines other
examples of restorative treatments
include Phoenix tears which can heal
someone even after a very severe
injuries case in point
Harry getting bitten unicorn hair which
is used for dressing wounds and even
unicorn blood if you dare which will
save you but at the cost of a cursed
existence number two if you look at the
15 most common causes of kicking the
bucket worldwide for muggles majority of
the list is treatable by Wizarding
medicine one of the main ones that isn't
would be a car accident but even then
whistles don't drive and they still may
be recoverable with something like
Phoenix's tears if they can get their
hands on them with all of that said the
average Wizarding life expectancy was
reported an average of a hundred and
thirty seven and three-quarters year old
in the mid-1990s this figure reported by
the ministry of divine health this means
they live an average of 73 percent
longer than humans who cap out at 79 I
do think that it is worth mentioning
however that the duration of their life
is incredibly hard to predict the oldest
known wizard on record was reported to
have reached the age of seven fifty-five
which far exceeds the average mentioned
above it was also reported in the
courser child that the trolley witch on
the hog was expressed had been working
on the train for 190 years at the point
of Albus Potter's fourth year perhaps
there are simply different tiers of
wizards or maybe it comes down to how
pure their bloodline is but one thing is
for sure they live a lot longer than us
muggles Sitz run the topic of ages I
thought that I'd provide you guys with
some ages of some of your favorite
characters Voldemort
aka Tom Riddle aka the Dark Lord was a
half-blood wizard intent on achieving
immortality interestingly enough he
faces untimely demise much younger than
average at the age of 71 Hagrid heckard
was only half wizard so the above
estimate may not apply to him
but he was reported to have been born in
1928 which means that he was 70 years
old at the Battle of Hogwarts Severus
Snape Snape was a half but wizard
reported to have been born in 1960 this
means that he met his untimely and
unfortunate fate at the age of 38
McGonigle this one is a bit of a cannon
blunder fantastic beasts 2 takes place
in near 1927 and features McGonagall in
her 20s
however JK Rowling revealed in the
original series and
we'll started teaching at the school in
1956 at the age of 21 in a 1995
conversation between Umbridge and
McGonagall McGonagall reveals that she
been working at Hogwarts 39 years this
December which is consistent with what
Rowling had said initially Pomona sprout
we know that sprout the head of
Hufflepuff house is two years old the
McGonagall which would make her 65
during the Battle of Hogwarts Dumbledore
the powerful Albus Percival Wulfric
Brian Dumbledore was born in 1881 and
passed away in June 1997 at the age of
115 Slughorn professor Horace Slughorn
zigzagged age is unconfirmed but we do
know that when he taught Tom Riddle he
was already getting on a bit if I had to
guess he was around thirty years older
than riddle at the time which would mean
that he was born in the year 1896 this
would mean that Slughorn was a hundred
and two during the Battle of Hogwarts
Bellatrix Bellatrix was 25 point to two
million years old wait no that's the
star Bellatrix Lestrange was born in
1951 and passed away at the age of 47
Nicholas Flamel
Nicholas Flamel was old and I mean old
he looked it he was born sometime
between the years 1300 and 1326 and
kicked the bucket sometime between 1992
and 1996 this means that he lived to
between 665 and 696 Lucius Malfoy Lucius
Malfoy okay Draco Malfoy his father is a
pure blood wizard born in 1953 at the
time of the Battle of Hogwarts
he was only 45 Alastor Moody though his
exact age is unconfirmed some sources
report that he was born in 1948 this
would mean that he was 49 at the time of
his demise
this seems accurate and that's it for
this video I hope you enjoyed it
and I hope that I was able to give you
some clarity on how long witches and
wizards actually live
until next time your wizard Harry
[Music]